what if the big company steals my idea I
got this question from one of my readers
oh Ken is my newsletter reader and he's
got a software business and he's worried
that if he puts out his software too
early a big companies going to come in
steal his idea and and rip him off using
me out of luck so I know this is a
legitimate fear okay and I mean I'm i
come from a software background I was my
first real successful business was in
software you have to understand though
how big companies work okay first of all
you could fly under the radar of a big
company for a long time big companies
are not paying attention to every little
company that comes along because there's
tons of them there's tons of these
startup companies and they're not paying
attention to them you could fly under
the radar for a long time okay second
big companies have production schedules
they plan up to a year in advance what
they're suffer is going to look like
whatever they're talking about now is it
isn't even going to be worked on for
another six months the idea of them
looking at what you're doing and then
suddenly changing right away and
implementing it is is tiny it doesn't
happen that's not how big companies
think Facebook doesn't want to create
their own Instagram they want to buy
instagram that's how big companies think
and that's the opportunity for you to
exit and the way you get bought out and
you're going to get to that decision
okay if you build this thing
successfully here's how acquisitions go
okay you want to get bought out by big
company this is how the process works I
went through it this is how it works the
company is going to look at what you
have they're gonna see how long is gonna
take the bill they're going to look to
their technology person say I want to
build what this guy has how long's gonna
take how much dollars they're going to
compute that see how much market share
you have how much momentum you have and
they're going to come with a price let
me say it's going to take us a year to
get there and then we're gonna have to
go out and get those customers that you
have instead of doing all that we're
just going to buy you out and that's how
most deals get made with these big
companies so it's to your advantage
to get your software out there quickly
get it out there get feedback get
momentum get some customers get some
money coming in poor back in your
development and grow this thing up as
fast as you can because until you start
getting feedback from your customers as
long as it's just an idea in your head
you know what I should release it it's
going to delay you getting this thing
out and there's other guys or just like
you just as hungry just as hustling out
there who are doing something similar
who've already launched something small
or who are about to launch something you
got to get ahead of those guys too
that's your real competition get it out
there get momentum get feedback get
customers build this thing up and by the
time you get on the radar of the big
companies they're going to want to buy
you out I know it's it's scary I know
you're worried that these guys are going
to steal what you have but you're better
off getting this thing out and building
momentum then just holding on to your
idea because if you just hold on to and
don't do anything with it you're not
going to have a business so get out
there work like hack get some customers
build some momentum and believe so those
you're watching like the video give it a
thumbs up below it makes you want to do
more for you leave a comment let me know
what you think you have a question
asking people Oh make a video response
and if you liked this video you can
subscribe to the channel so you can see
more just like this thank you so much
and I'll see you soon